[Music]
thank you very much secretary Bernhardt
we also have with us a very special
people Congressman Jim Jordan
congressman mark meadows and
representative John Ratcliffe it's an
honor to be with everyone tonight and
all across our LED milani and i would
like to wish you a very very Merry
Christmas and now the first lady will do
the honors of lighting the National
Christmas tree so we'll count from five
down to that very special number five
four three two one
[Applause]
and let us show our appreciation to the
incredible workers at the Department of
the Interior and the National Park
Service please did such an incredible
job thank you very much and thank you as
well to the US Marine Corps band and the
Tucson Arizona Boys Choir you know that
the chorus is fantastic and thank you
very much Tucson Arizona thank you very
much I also want to thank a special
group of young wonderful people West
Tennessee youth chorus they're here and
they're doing beautifully
in 1923 President Calvin Coolidge lit
the first national Christmas tree
later that night African American
community centers held it out to a
worship service on these grounds and
during that service the Washington
Monument was illuminated with a
beautiful cross a powerful reminder of
the meaning of Christmas more than two
thousand years ago a brilliant star
shone in the east wise men traveled far
far afield I mean they were a long
distance away and they came and they
stood with us under the star where they
found the Holy Family in Bethlehem as
the Bible tells us when the wise men had
come into the house they saw the young
child with Mary his mother and fell down
and worshiped him Christian's give
thanks that the Son of God came into the
world to save humanity Jesus Christ
inspires us to love one another with
hearts full of generosity and grace
joining us today are David and Sharon
Hudson of the Salvation Army each year
through their Angel Tree program The
Salvation Army brings new gifts to more
than 600,000 children David and Sharon
aren't inspiration to us all in David
and Sharon thank you very much for being
with us thank you
also with us is Sarah Verado the wife of
a wounded hero and the CEO of
Independence Fund which serves wounded
warriors during the holidays Sarah gives
high-tech wheelchairs to veterans and
hosts Christmas celebrations for those
in recovery does a fantastic job and
Sarah thank you very much your uplifting
our nation thank you very much thank you
Sarah
thank you we are forever in debt to the
brave veterans and servicemembers we
applaud their noble service there is
nobody like them they are an inspiration
to us all we also salute our incredible
police and Sheriff's federal law
enforcement Secret Service as well as
our firefighters paramedics and first
responders and thank you all for being
here we have a lot of you here and again
very very incredible special people
thank you very much for being here and
here tonight is Pastor Obed waragi of
Bethany church in Nazarene in Miami his
congregation serves Thanksgiving meals
to families in need and now they are
preparing their annual toy drive
pastor Obed thank you very much and we
really do appreciate you being with us
you're a special man who has done an
incredible job people are talking about
you all over our country what a great
job you've done thank you very much
faster
[Applause]
then at Christmas we remember this
eternal truth every person is a beloved
child of God as one grateful nation we
praise the joy of family the blessings
of freedom and the miracle of Christmas
on behalf of Melania and our entire
family Merry Christmas and God bless you
all thank you very much
Merry Christmas everybody
[Applause]